birds are really weird in so many ways
they have such a short stubby tail mane
even shorter than in a mammal they have
this really crouched kind of zigzag
legged posture of course they can fly
their body form is is bizarre compared
to almost anything else living so I
really like the question of well how did
they get to be that way me it's it's the
question of bipedality I'm interested in
things walking on two legs with SH I
mean in the modern world is basically
limited to us and birds when humans walk
around we tend to walk around when
fairly straight legs our legs act
somewhat like a column so they support
our weight so I'm using mainly the bones
it's a very straight line from our
center of mass that average position of
our bodyweight straight down the leg
whereas when Birds stand they have very
bent legs at these very zigzag legs
which mechanically it is slightly
counterintuitive because it takes a lot
more muscular effort to stand like that
alright time to see the birds so check
out the posture of the leg is really
interesting that the knee is there and
then we go down to the ankle and of
course the toes
so it's a very crouched posture with the
especially the hip and the knee very
bent the thigh almost horizontal like
this so I got a posture like that the
question we were interested in is how
did birds get like this and we decided
to look at the ancestors of birds to try
and get an answer to this question so we
decided to look at dinosaurs
one of the best fossil records of any
vertebrate group is the dinosaur lineage
and that shows how birds got the way
they are today we just need to put it
together in a computer and track the
evolution of fossils we know and that
allows us to reconstruct how body form
and therefore posture evolved so once
you have your digitized dinosaur
skeleton this is a Tyrannosaur here you
can then start what we call shrink-wrap
it so start to place simple geometry
around the body which we do by just
fitting these very simple hoop like
shapes around it and from this we can
expand it into a volumetric model and
from this it's relatively simple to
calculate what we call the mass
properties that is the weight and the
position of the center of mass of this
entire complex shape so in our models we
chose animals that were represented by
good skeletons that were three
dimensionally preserved pretty well and
that represented the key changes in the
anatomy of dinosaurs from big heavy
tailed two-legged dinosaurs like T Rex
to later kind of short tailed or more
rod-like tailed larger foreland animals
like Archaeopteryx and velociraptor
the crocodile really nicely represents
the body form that dinosaurs ultimately
evolved from the common ancestor of
crocodiles birds and extinct dinosaurs
was all it was rather like a crocodile
in many ways in its general shape so we
look at the crocodile huge muscular tail
here it's very much like what dinosaurs
started off with early in their
evolution and short little fore limbs
slightly larger more muscular hind limbs
nice big head full of teeth a very
different kind of body form than a bird
like this frozen pheasant we have here
or like the turkeys that we have around
our lab or the emus we thought just like
everyone else that as dinosaur tails
shortened and became lighter the center
of mass moved forward and that was the
conventional story well our computer
modeling that Vivian and others did
showed that the center of mass of
dinosaurs did move forwards toward the
head during their evolution but it
wasn't really the tail that drove that
change of center of mass during the
revolution was it viv well according to
our results there's a stronger
association between the development of
large forearms I mean the things that
eventually become the wings of birds and
that it was this this trend towards
larger arms and was driving the center
of mass forwards more than the tail and
that change of center of mass forwards
would have required the animals to stand
in a more and more crouched posture so
going from a straight legged kind of
posture like in humans almost yeah to a
more crouched posture which birds have
today more and more like the obvious
question when dealing with anything
about the evolution of locomotion in
birds is is this associated with flight
and our results suggests that in a way
yes if you have these very large
forearms for flying then because of the
effect on the position of the center of
mass this will never tably change how
your hind ends works or what your hind
limb posture is but this is something
that starts a lot
earlier than flight so a lot of
non-flying dinosaurs particularly the
bird-like dinosaurs like velociraptor
and its relatives had very long arms
which were presumably for something like
prey manipulation or something like this
and this is this development of long
arms that kind of kick-started the shift
towards crouched posture which was then
inherited by flying animals and became
sort of emphasized as the four arms got
even larger to work as wings so I think
that's really interesting that there's a
link between the way the hind legs work
the way the animal stands and moves but
also mechanically through the physics of
movement the changes of the center of
mass would have influenced the way the
animals flew and ultimately allowed
perhaps flight to evolve
you